Alzubillahim na Shaytana Rajing Basillahur Rahmanur Rahim Alhamdulillahi Khalikal Wujudim in Al-Adam Wa Ja'ilin Noori Minazulam Wa Mukhrijis Sabri Minal-Alam Wa Mulkitawbati Alan Nadam Fanashkuruhu Alan Masaibi Kamanashkuruhu Alan Na'am Wa Nusalli Ala Rasul Hilakram Lis Sharafila Sham Wa Nuril Atam Wa Kitabil Makam Wa Kamalin Nabiyina Wal Khatam
Sayyidi waladiyadam Alladi Bashar Rabhi Aisab Numariyam Wada Ali Baisatihi Ibrahimu Alaihis Salaam Hina Kaana Yarfa'u Kawa ila Baitillahil Muharram Fas Allahu Alaihi wa Alaihi wa Sallam Wa Ala Adba'i Khairul Ummam Alladina Barak Allahu Bihim Ka Fatan nass Al Arabam inhum wal Ajam
Wa sallallahu ala amir al mu'mineen alanza al-bateen Waqa'id al-gur al-mahjaleen ghalib ala kulli ghalib matloobi kulli taalib Mawlana ali ibni abi taalib Alhamdulillah, al-lazi anzala ala abdihil kitab, walam yaja'allahu aywaja, walhamdulillah, al-lazi lam yat takhiz waladan walam yakun lahu shalikun fil mulk, walam yakun lahu wali yum minazul lay wa kabbir hu tadbira
Alhamdulillah al-adinahmaduhu wa nastaainuhu wa nastaghfiruhu wa nu'minu bihi wa na tawakkalu 'alai Wa na augubillahi min shuruli anfusina wa min sayyi'ati 'amalina Ban yahdihillahu fala mudillala Wa man yudlilhu fala hadi Allah Wa nashaduan la ilaha illa Allah wahdahula sharikala Wa nashadu Anna Muhammadul Abdullahi wa rasuli arsalahuullahu ta'ala bilhuda wadin al-haq Liyuzhirahu al-dinikullay wakafa bilahi shahidah
Wa nashadwa na mawlana ali ibnabi taalib wasiyu wa waziru fa sallallahu alayhim wa ala alayhim wa salim hum tasliman kathiran kathira Allahum mala ailmalana ila ma alamtana inna kaantal alimul Hakeem Allahum ma alim na bimayan fa'ana wa yan fa'ana bima alamtala Allahum ma inna na uzubika min ail min la yanfa wa min kalbin la yaksha wa min aainin la tadma wa min nafsin la tashfa
Faamma baadiyakulu subhana wa ta'ala fi kitabihil kareem Baadanakula audubillahi mina shaytan regim Bismillahur Rahmanur Raheem Rabbish Rahli sadri wa yaserli amri Wahlul qdatamil lithani yaf kahu kawli Allahum masabbidna aindal maltibila ilaha illa Allah wallahum majal namin aladina amanu amil al salihat Watawa sahubil haq wa tawa sahubil Sabaq Amin ya Rabbil Alameen once again assalam alaikum wa rahmatallahi wa barakatu
So, in the previous session, we studied a couple of composite words like ilah and arab.
I explained that the word ilah is a composition of several different meanings.
You know, it comes from alaha ya'aluhu, the one who is worthy of worship.
Then there is Alaha, which is used for a child that is thirsty for the milk of its mother.
Basically, the one who we desperately turn to for the fulfillment of our needs.
That's basically Alaha.
Then there's Walaha, the one that we are passionately in love with.
There's Aliha, the one we lean on or we put our weight on.
There is Waliha, which is
to become astounded by the glory and the magnificence of someone right so when we combine all of these meanings together we get an understanding of what the word ilah means and then we looked at our credal formula la ilaha illallah which is basically designed to eliminate the multiplicity of these these generic ilah right and to identify that one specific ilah
so basically we apply the the article the definite article of the to the ilah and we make him al-ilah and you know that the combination of al-ilah is what Allah basically is so you know we looked at that in the previous we compared that to the concept of idol worship and breaking idols and things like that then we looked at the word rab which is also a composite word you know
it's a combination of these six meanings Malik being the absolute owner Sayyad being the one who has complete authority Murabbi is the one who nourishes takes care ensures growth right Murshad is the which comes from Rushd which means the guide and the one who puts to purpose
the benevolent benefactor, the one who showers with undeserving gifts.
Qayyim, the maintainer, the sustainer.
So you combine all of these six meanings, these six images, these six concepts and you understand what the word Rabd means, which we translate as Master.
Then we looked at the concept of Aabd which is the Quranic perspective and it means
you know, a free slave, as opposed to forced slavery, the Quranic concept of Aad is a free slave.
And in order to understand that relationship, we looked at this master-slave relationship that we find in the world, and then we compared that relationship to the master-slave relationship that Allah talks about in the Quran.
And after that analysis we concluded that even though Allah is a master, He is unlike any other master that we have or will encounter in this world.
So that's pretty much the things that we talked about in the previous sessions.
Today we're going to look at the word Rahma which is the primary attribute of Allah.
it is actually an attribute that is the most dear to Allah in fact this quality is so fundamental to him that we learned that he has actually made it obligatory on himself okay so we know that Allah has imposed certain obligations on all Muslims right as soon as you become a Muslim there are certain obligations that
There are certain actions that become compulsory for Muslims.
You know, Salat, prayers, fasting, Zakat, Hajj, right?
These are all, you know, a bunch of actions that Allah has made compulsory on all Muslims.
But there is one action that Allah has actually made compulsory on Himself.
And that is the action of His mercy.
It is the action of His Rahma.
So, there is a Hadith in which Rasulullah says that ..................
So, he says that indeed when Allah established all of creation, right, when He was done creating everything, He wrote a statement on His throne
He wrote a statement on His throne.
And what was that statement?
Indeed, My mercy for all My creation will always overcome and overpower My wrath and My anger.
In other words, in My dealing with My creation,
My mercy will always supersede my anger.
My Rahma will always supersede my anger.
Mercy is not...
Well, I'll talk about that in a bit.
But basically He says that my Rahma will always overpower my anger.
And this is a rule that our all-powerful, almighty Creator imposed upon Himself in His dealings
with His creation with us SubhanAllah now of course this is not literal right you understand that there's not like an actual physical throne that He sits on and then there is this you know the statement written on that throne it's just a graphic representation of an emotion right it's a visual representation of an emotion that depicts the love of Allah for His creation so we know that why do we write down things
and why do we and why would so imagine if this somebody has a throne a king has a throne and he is writing something on that throne what what's the idea behind that right in the human context it's a constant reminder you know a king is about to sit on a throne and the first thing he looks is looks at that is that statement and he's like oh okay so now I have to deal with my subjects with mercy right so that's the that's the
the physical human representation of that emotion it's not...
so this hadith is not literal but you get the idea that Allah has basically imposed this rule upon Himself that inna rahmati taghul ibu ghadhabi my mercy is always going to take precedence over my anger and my wrath so it's a beautiful hadith that depicts this emotion of love that Allah has for His creation
So now let's look at the word Rahma itself.
It's a very powerful word that we will study over the course of the next few sessions.
It's too much to cover into you know it's too broad to cover in one session.
We'll start gradually today we'll look at the general definition of the word Rahma.
okay in the next session we'll look at a more graphic representation of the word and that'll help us visualize this concept properly because we talk about Rahma all the time we talk about Allah's mercy all the time but do we have a clear image of what that word means?
we don't actually in most cases we don't and if you look at the translation of this word Rahma in English you know what do we how do we translate Rahma in English?
Mercy.
Now the problem with that translation is that it actually distorts the meaning of the word.
I'm not saying that it's the wrong translation but I am saying that it's a weak translation.
Why?
Because the word mercy is generally used when you are being spared from a punishment.
So when you hear the words the soldier showed mercy what does that mean?
Right?
It means that they had the power to do something terrible but then they chose not to do it and to spare everyone.
The criminal begged the judge for mercy.
so the whole begging thing and the whole you know begging for that mercy it creates this image in other words he asked the judge to be spared to not be punished basically right so when we generally think of the word mercy the idea is that something bad or something painful was about to happen and then somebody decided not to go ahead with that painful action in other words you know showed mercy
You understand?
So there is this subconscious association with punishment when the word mercy is used followed by the idea of somehow escaping that punishment.
But nevertheless the default position is pretty much punishment when we think of mercy.
So now what happens is that when we constantly use this word mercy for Allah with that subconscious taint of escaping punishment
And when we constantly keep saying it, you know, Bismillah, Rahman, Rahman, Rahman, everywhere in the Quran, Rahman, that word Rahman is being constantly used, you know, He's extremely merciful, extreme.
When we keep repeating it over and over again, it creates this idea in our minds that Allah wanted to do something bad to us, like He has this power to do bad to us, but then He decides not to do it to us, right?
So that's how He showed us mercy by not punishing us.
So you see what I'm saying?
It's subtle but it creates the subconscious image of Allah being the tyrant in some sense who then chooses not to go ahead with His act right?
Nauzubillah it creates that sort of...
it taints imamate of Allah in that sense.
Now in reality it is absolutely not true.
That is not the true intent of the word Rahma.
The word rahma has absolutely nothing to do with punishment.
It has no concept of the word punishment in it.
So I think it's really good to linguistically understand the proper meaning of this word as the ancient Arabs understood it so that we can really appreciate the next time we talk about or we hear the rahma of Allah we really get an image, a clear understanding of what that word means.
So I'm going to share this image
I hope everybody's logged into the website.
Okay, so in classical Arabic, Rahma has four meanings.
It's a composite word and these four words or these four meanings come together to explain the meaning of the word Rahma.
The first is unconditional love.
It is care, genuine concern and mercy.
That's what Rahma means.
It's a combination of these four things: unconditional love, extreme care, genuine concern and then mercy.
Mercy is actually the last piece of the puzzle, not the first.
Unconditional love is the first.
Then comes care, then comes concern and then finally mercy.
That is Rahma.
now these four words are quite self-explanatory right unconditional love is affection without conditions we know that Allah loves his creation unconditionally like the mother who loves all her children equally regardless of whether they are obedient or disobedient doesn't matter right it doesn't really matter to the mother in terms of her love for them she still loves them it's the same way Allah loves us the same you know
And why not?
We're all His creation after all.
I mean He created us with His own hands He tells us in the Quran.
He didn't set up a factory, send us off or you know outsource the job of human creation to angels or anything like that right?
The Quran tells us that I created you with my own hands.
In the story of Adam we know that He created Adam with his own hands.
So there's that you know that closeness
Because what do we do, right?
When we get disconnected and we want to create something in bulk, we set up a factory, we outsource it, we do things like that.
Nowhere in the Quran does Allah say that he outsourced the job of creating this universe.
He did the whole thing by himself.
So that establishes that closeness, that emotion of, okay, this is very personal, you know, human beings are a very personal creation to Allah .
And so there's no surprise that He loves them unconditionally.
So that's unconditional love.
Allah is caring.
He looks after us, provides for us, fulfills all our needs, right?
He's genuinely and sincerely concerned for our salvation, for our happiness, for our well-being.
That's why He sends the Quran, the messengers, constant reminders, constant teachings.
constant wake-up calls right because He's concerned that He wants us to be happy He wants us to achieve eternal happiness so there's that genuine concern there and finally Allah is merciful in that He shows compassion towards our weakness right He graciously forgives our sins and our transgressions and He accepts our weak and feeble acts of worship
even though they lack the sincerity and the honor that He deserves.
I mean, we pray, but half the time we're on Amazon shopping while we're praying, right?
So, you know, and Allah could just throw that prayer away and He could say, you know, I don't want this kind of a connection, but He's merciful in that He accepts that, He wholeheartedly accepts that anything that we offer to Him.
so you know so he's merciful in the fact that he shows that compassion towards our weakness so Rahma is a combination of these four words put together unconditional love, extreme care, genuine concern and mercy but what's interesting is that linguistically speaking the word Rahma means to have these four things in order to benefit someone that's the primary condition of Rahma
it's not just you know love for the sake of love or care or concern for the sake of it it actually has to have an end result and that end result is to benefit someone so the ancient Arab for him he would define Rahma as Rahma is a kind of love it is a kind of tenderness
that is intended to benefit the beloved in other words Rahma is precisely targeted towards benefiting someone it has to translate into some sort of a beneficial action otherwise it's not Rahma you see it's service Rahma is
manifests itself in a form of service otherwise it's not really Rahma so that's the most important thing that you know you can have all these emotions but if it doesn't actually you know how Allah says that if you love me then show me?
He imposes the same rule on Himself this is the most amazing thing about Allah that He's extremely fair not just with us but with Himself so whatever He imposes on us He imposes on Himself too
You know, he says that, you know, just saying that you love me is not just having love for me is not enough.
Just saying it is not enough.
I need to see it in action.
He imposes the same rule on himself.
He's like, I have Rahma for you.
I have love for you.
I care about you.
I'm concerned about you.
I will have mercy on you and I will show it to you.
So that you know that that benefit is it manifests in that in the form of that benefit.
Now
Today what I want to focus on in today's session is these two commonly used words of Rahma.
So there are two common flavors or manifestations of this word Rahma that we find in the Quran that is used over and over again right and those words are Ar-Rahman and Ar-Raheen and both those words they originate from Rahma.
So let's first look at how both these words are commonly translated so that we can appreciate when we learn its real meaning.
We'll go into a lot of depth into these words today.
But just to start off, if you look at the translation of these words in English, right?
Bismillahirahmanir Raheem.
How is that normally translated?
In the name of Allah, the Most Gracious, the Most Merciful.
or you will find in the name of Allah the most beneficent the most merciful the most merciful the most kind the most merciful the beneficent the beneficent the beneficent the problem with these translations is that you know these words are very difficult to process and visualize in English I mean when do we ever use the word
beneficient in our normal day conversations like if somebody help you with something do you say oh gee you are so beneficient.
No you don't do that right.
The purpose of translation is to understand the text better but if we start using words for translations that we ourselves do not use in normal conversations or words we cannot relate to
then it kind of defeats the entire purpose and then we sort of just form some sort of a concept about that word.
So today I want to focus on these two words so that we really appreciate how do we visualize Allah and His Rahma when we call Him a Rahman and Raheem.
So as I said both these words are Rahman and Raheem, they both manifest from the word Rahma.
And I just explained what rahma is.
It is a combination of four things that are intended to benefit someone.
Unconditional love, care, concern, and mercy.
So when we say Allah is ar-Rahman and ar-Raheen, we are essentially acknowledging these four qualities about Allah.
Okay?
That's the implicit acknowledgement in any word that derives from the word rahma.
And this is something that Allah states in the Quran over and over again.
There are so many verses that talk about His Rahmah.
The Quran in itself is a manifestation of His Rahmah, right?
Out of His love He created night and day.
out of His love, He made your tasks easy for you right?
out of His love, He sends you winds that deliver good tidings so that you can taste, you can recognize His love for you, you can recognize His rashma for you
When Allah opens the door of His love for someone, nothing can close them.
So there are numerous verses in the Quran that talk about Allah's Rahma and the purpose of all such verses is to explain one thing to us.
In the last session we talked about Allah being our master, Rab, right?
And when we think of the word master in the worldly sense, when you think of the word authority, what is the last thing you think of in a master-slave relationship?
Unconditional love.
Right?
But Allah is reminding us right away, right at the beginning of every recitation, we start every recitation with Bismillahir Rashmanir Rahim.
So, every time we begin reciting his message, he is reminding us that he's a different kind of master.
He's reminding us that we will never ever find a master in this world who is as powerful as Allah and yet who has the kind of Rashmah that he has.
Because no other master in this world will show unconditional love to his slaves.
They might take care of their slaves
once in a while right but they will never ever love them we know in this world masters will always show love to their own never to their slaves because it is beneath them
Because they enjoy a much higher social status than a slave and therefore they will never associate themselves with the slave.
Forget unconditional love.
But this master, our master, what is the comparison between...
We're not talking human to human.
We're talking creator to creation.
Right?
And that's where he shines so bright in which...
in there that he is a master, a powerful master, Allah.
But the very first emotion that he exhibits towards us is unconditional love.
No other master will care for us the way Allah cares for us.
No other master will be more genuinely concerned for us than Allah is concerned for us.
No other master will show us mercy and compassion when we disobey them, not do the task assigned to us, do not fulfill the task to their standards,
No master will show the kind of compassion and mercy and forgiveness to us in the way Allah does it for us.
So that's the first thing to understand.
The whole purpose of these verses of Rahma is for us to realize what an incredible master we have, for us to appreciate that.
So now let's understand these words linguistically.
And inshallah this will blow your mind because once you understand these words you can really appreciate Allah like nothing else.
So I'll begin with Ar-Rahman, okay?
The word Ar-Rahman, it follows a particular phonetic pattern that represents intensity, ferocity, you know, severity.
It's a pattern that represents extreme force or power.
Now any word in Arabic that follows this phonetic pattern of aan has these characteristics.
So you know words like hadbaan which means extremely angry, intensely angry, jawan extremely
hungry ferociously hungry right Achshan extremely thirsty so it's this pattern that have this this common sound right Ghadbaan Jawaan Achshan so on the same fanatic pattern we have the word Rahman extremely merciful intensely merciful you understand
Now what's really interesting is that any word in the Quran in ancient Arabic that follows this phonetic pattern it has to have three it will always have these three characteristics.
It's going to be extreme it's going to be immediate but it's going to be temporary.
All words that match this pattern will always possess these three characteristics.
They will be extreme
They will be immediate and they will be temporary.
So now if you look at the word Rahman, it means love, care, concern and mercy of Allah.
But not just love in the sense we understand love.
It is a very extreme and intense form of love.
It is the kind of love that is beyond human imagination.
it is care and concern beyond human imagination it is mercy and forgiveness and compassion and all of those things beyond human imagination or example and you will not find any example in this world in human existence that can compare to the Rahma of Allah so that's the first characteristics of Rahma that whatever you expect from Allah in terms of love care concern and mercy
First thing to understand is that it is going to be beyond your imagination and expectation.
You will never be able to find an example of that kind of love and concern in this world.
Right?
That's the first thing.
The second characteristic of Rashman is that it is something that is happening immediately.
You don't have to wait for it.
It is happening right now.
So let's think about this for a second.
In English, what is the difference between someone who is patient and someone who is being patient?
Which of the two is showing patience right now?
The one who is being patient, right?
Like for example, if I say that so-and-so is a patient woman You know
she might she is a patient woman but I can't say that if she's going crazy right now with her kids or not you know maybe she's yelling at them maybe she's throwing them against the wall I don't know when I say so and so is a patient woman what I'm basically saying is that she is generally a patient person that does not necessarily mean that she is acting patiently right this very second but when I say that you know this woman is being patient I'm talking about her
right now.
So you understand the difference?
The love and the care of Ar-Rahman is not something that is happening generally or at some distant point in time.
That extreme and intense form of love is happening right now.
In other words through the word Ar-Rahman the Quran is teaching us that we don't have to wait for Allah to show us love
at some future point in time.
We don't have to wait for Allah to care for us, be concerned for us, show us compassion at a later point in time when some event occurs or when we are in the middle of some calamity.
No, no, no, no.
All of that is happening right now.
You understand?
He loves us
cares for us, concerns for us, is compassionate towards us extremely, intensely.
When?
Right now.
He is being extremely compassionate to us right now, every single waking moment.
All of that is happening in its extreme form right now.
So the first characteristic of Ar-Rahman is that it is extremely intense, the second is that it is immediate.
What was the third one?
The third is temporary.
The love of Ar-Rahman is extreme, it is intense, it is immediate, but it is temporary.
It's not permanent.
Now, this third part is a bit hard to take in when we hear it for the first time, you know, it sort of kind of feels wrong.
you know how can that be but I'll explain that so just bear with me for a bit and you'll understand the context of why I say it's temporary but for now just understand that Ar-Rahman has these three qualities intense, immediate and temporary and as I said all words that follow this phonetic pattern they have these characteristics so let's understand it this way if you look at the word of Adhaban it means extremely angry
Intensely angry, fuming with anger.
It's not like just regular anger.
It's like, you know, it's where you end up killing someone.
It's that kind of an anger.
But the thing is with that extreme anger, it has to be temporary.
Think about it.
It has to be temporary.
Why?
Because someone who is extremely angry, he cannot possibly sustain that anger physically forever.
He cannot.
His head will explode.
He will die.
Right?
Even the Hulk chills out eventually.
So, Ghadaban, even though it's an extreme state, it's an immediate state, it cannot last forever.
Either he's going to burst out, he's going to do what he needs to do and then calm down, or he will blow a fuse in his head and die basically.
But it cannot last.
That state, that intense state cannot last.
Similarly Jauhan, extremely hungry.
And hungry when?
Right now.
Like you crazy teenagers, right?
But temporary.
Because you will eat something in that state and once you do your hunger goes away.
Or if you don't eat, you starve to death.
And that's how...
that your hunger goes away.
In either case hunger goes away.
It does not permit...
that intense hunger does not permanently stay there.
Same with akshan.
You know extremely thirsty right this very moment but temporary.
You either have a drink and then you're no longer thirsty or you die of thirst.
In other words...
in either case the thirst is not going to last forever.
So now why is Allah's intense mercy temporary?
Because we would not be able to handle the intensity and the severity of His love for a long period of time.
Just as I gave you the example of Jawan, Achaan, Ghadban, we would not be able to, we would go insane.
I'll give you a
an example I mean kids will be able to understand and relate to this much better but have you ever had those moments where your mom you know where where they're in this cuddly and huggy kind of mood and they wrap their arms around you and squeeze you till you just cannot breathe anymore and all made-up but you know right until your face is dripping wet you know what I'm talking about
Now that is a manifestation of what?
It's a manifestation of intense love.
It is a burst of love, a burst of this energy that your mother feels and she just has to shower that love on you.
And that's a beautiful thing.
It's an extremely beautiful thing when you're feeling down or when you're depressed and you just need some serious TLC.
That is great.
You actually appreciate that intense love.
Right?
But now imagine that every time you walk by your mother, that's what she does to you.
Every time you walk past, she goes, Oh, Mera Bachan.
Right?
Every single time.
How would you feel then?
Would you be able to take it?
No.
You'd get annoyed.
You'd get irritated.
It's like, Mom, leave me alone.
Stop marinating my face with your saliva every time I walk by.
Right?
So you get the idea.
So Allah's intense love is extreme, it's immediate but it has to be temporary because if it was constant, if he burst that love out on us constantly it would drive us insane and there are examples of people who have gone insane.
So
So that's the idea behind, because anything that is intense, it cannot be sustained for a long time.
I mean, if you're jogging, if you're on the treadmill, and if you put the treadmill to the highest speed and you get this burst where you're just running, great.
You can expend a lot of energy when you do that, but you cannot just keep going on.
You eventually have to slow down, right?
That same principle that applies to any word that basically follows this phonetic pattern.
So Ar-Rahman, three things to understand about Ar-Rahman is that it is intense, it is immediate, and because of that it is also temporary.
Right?
Okay.
The next word is Ar-Raheem.
Allah's love, care, concern, and mercy, it also manifests through the word Raheem.
And there are two characteristics that you need to know about the word Rahim.
And once again, this applies to all words that follow this phonetic pattern, right?
Kareem, Salim, Hakim, Jamil, Jaleel.
They all have these qualities, the same two qualities.
What are they?
The first is that they are permanent.
They are not temporary.
The second quality is that it is not necessarily happening right now.
It is not immediate.
It is long-term.
For example, if I say, you know, my khala loves me or my khala is loving to me, that's a long-term quality, right?
But does that mean that she's being loving to me right now?
No, not necessarily.
She may not be showering me with love this very moment but I know for sure that it's always there for me.
That's the difference between these two words.
Now what's really interesting is that everywhere in the Quran we find Ar-Rahman mentioned first and then it is followed by Ar-Raheem.
Right?
Now why is that?
And why are the two always used together?
And this is where it gets really interesting.
See, if Allah had only said Ar-Rahman then His love, His care, His concern, His mercy would have been extreme, it would have been immediate, but it wouldn't have been permanent.
If Allah had only said Ar-Rahim his love and his mercy would have been permanent but it would not have been extreme.
So how do I talk about the love, care, concern and mercy of Allah so that it is extreme and it is beyond expectations and it is immediate and it is permanent and it is long-term
And it is all of that at the same time, the only way to express that is through Ar-Rahman and Ar-Rahim, together, SubhanAllah.
So you cannot understand, we're taking an intangible emotion and we're trying to confine that in words.
To express what, to visualize again an understanding of what that really means.
So, you know, there could be no better way of expressing these qualities of love, care and concern of Allah better than Ar-Rahman and Ar-Rahim.
Let me give you an example so that you understand this better.
You are at work, right?
Today is fading.
Your boss is not there at the office and you have a flight booked, you know.
to Timbuktu let's say for 6 you know 6 o'clock in the evening 6 p.m.
which means that you need to leave the office exactly at 5 o'clock or you will not be at the airport it's already 4 45 right you've got 15 minutes left and you still haven't received your paycheck and and you desperately need your paycheck because that money is for this trip you know you were counting on this paycheck for the expenses on this for this trip
So now you're getting desperate.
It's 4:50 now and your boss still isn't there.
So you're getting extremely anxious.
And your co-worker comes up to you and says, Don't worry, our boss is reliable.
He'll be here.
You'll get your paycheck.
Don't worry, relax.
55, you've got five minutes left and you're totally freaking out.
Your co-worker is still telling you, Don't worry, don't worry, he's reliable, he'll be here.
now what would you say to that co-worker at that point you'll say listen I know he's reliable but I need him to be reliable right now right this very minute I need his quality of reliability right now you see when I'm in serious trouble I need Allah's help when right now
So I need the name of Allah that gives me that help that I need right now.
That is Ar-Rashman.
But then I also need the other name of Ar-Rahim because that takes care of my future.
When Allah says Ar-Rahim it is permanent, right?
Which is a guarantee for what?
The future.
So Ar-Rahman is a guarantee of his love, his care, his concern and his mercy for the immediate, for the present, whereas Ar-Rahim is a guarantee of his love, his care, his concern and mercy for the future.
In other words, both short term and long term are covered by the attributes of Ar-Rahman and Ar-Rahim.
I'll give you another example.
I come home
I'm really really hungry I'm starving I didn't have time for breakfast I was too busy at work couldn't have lunch so now I come home in the evening and I'm dying right I sit at the dining table you know my wife comes up to me and says so what do you think we should go I should cook for next week I'll be like woman
Who cares about next week?
Give me something right now.
Right?
When you're extremely hungry, the only thing you can think of is what?
Right now.
And then when my right now is taken care of, once I've finished eating my dinner, right?
Once I've taken care of my right now, I will say only then I will be interested in what I'm going to eat next week, right?
Only after you've paid the bills for this month you will start worrying about the next month.
Only after you've paid the fees for this semester you will start worrying about the fees for next semester.
You understand?
So we only think about our future...
we can only think about our future when our immediate concerns are taken care of.
So Allah says I am a Rahman
I am taking care of your immediate needs right now, but when your immediate concerns are taken care of, I am also a Rahim.
I will also take care of all your future concerns.
Right?
So I hope that gives...
You know, somebody asked Ibn Abbas who wants about the difference between Rahman and Rahim and I think he gave a very beautiful explanation.
He said, Allah
is ar-Rahman to us in this life and he is ar-Raheen to us in the afterlife because we know that the love and care of Allah it goes away for disbelievers on the day of judgment right until that day he is you know ar-Rahman for both the believers and the disbelievers he is ar-Rahman for all of us every human being
In other words, the Ar-Rahman, he does not only care about Sulaimanis or about Muslims, he cares about everyone.
His love, his care, his concern for every single human being that he ever created, you know, plants, animals, humans, whatever.
No matter what religion, color or race they belong to, he actually loves and cares for them.
He even loves and cares for those who hate him, who deny his existence.
His doors of Rahmania are always open to everyone.
because he's always hoping that they will choose to turn back to him his invitation never expires his invitation his arms you know he extends he opens his arms for us and that that invitation never expires because Rahman is a universal quality My mercy extends to all the Quran says
the rain comes down from the sky for all creation human beings drink from it we all draw our sustenance from it right the good drinks the wretched drinks the sinner drinks the pious drinks the friends of Allah drinks the enemy of Allah's drink so everybody drinks this is a universal mercy of his right so Allah's Rahma his Rahmaniyah
is open for everybody and he is Rahim in that same sense that he takes care of everybody their long-term concerns he has a plan for everyone you know eventually we know that everyone is going to come into the fold of Islam and everybody will eventually enter Jannah because that is what he wants that is what he's designed this everything to work with so his mercy is just incredible
I mean, there's just no words to explain it.
There's this hadith.
It's such a beautiful hadith.
I think to me, personally, I think it's one of the most...
it's one of those things that really brings home to me this concept of His mercy.
There's a...
Rasulullah tells us that there's a Hadith in which he says ...
...
He says that not a single day passes that the ocean asks its master, Ya Allah, give me permission
Let me drown these disbelievers.
Let me, you know, drown these disobedient creatures.
They enjoy your blessings and they rebel against you.
Give me permission.
Allow me.
Let me teach them a lesson.
The earth begs its master, Ya Allah.
Allow me to swallow them alive.
Allow me to eat them up right where they stand.
They walk on your earth, they eat from its produce, that you grow from them, and then they do not prostrate to you, they do not do sajdah before you in abject humiliation.
Let me teach them a lesson, let me remove them from the face of this earth.
Angels say, Ya Allah, give us permission, let us destroy them, let us annihilate them.
They don't deserve to live after what you do for them, the kind of love, the kind of care, the kind of concern and mercy you show them, the way they respond back to you, they do not deserve to exist.
Let us annihilate them.
Right?
The ocean, the earth, the angels, what are they?
They're creations of Allah, just like us.
Allah created them they are watching us they are watching our sins they are watching our rebellion and they're getting furious and they're just like creations like us but the Creator that we are all rebelling against what did He say how did He respond to them leave them let them be
I love my creation way more than how you are imagining it if these are your creation Allah is talking to the ocean the earth and the angels if these are your creation then do whatever you want with them go ahead if they are your creation but if they are my creation
then just hand them over to Me and step out of the way.
I will deal with My creation, My way.
And in the Yas alul malaika, salimaza akduhu, the angels ask him, What are you waiting for?
Yas tajibullah, innani attaliyaw illa tauba Allah responds to them and says, I am waiting for their repentance.
In atani naharan kabil tahu, in atani lailan kabil tahu.
If they approach me during the daytime, I will accept them.
If they approach me in the nighttime, I will accept them.
If anyone takes one step, if anyone will take one step towards me, I will run towards them.
And if anyone runs towards me, I will bring him closer.
And if anyone walks away from me, if anyone turns away from me and walks away from me, I will go after him, I will chase him.
I mean, how beautiful is that?
if anyone takes one single step towards me I will run towards him and if somebody walks away from me I will chase him this is Allah speaking to him you know this is Allah dealing with his creations it's not just you know it's incredible does Allah need to do that if
Anyone walks away from me, I will chase them.
I will go after him in order to bring him closer to me.
And I will ask him, Awala karabbu ghairi?
Do you have another master who is more loving than me?
Awala karabbu ghairi, do you see another master that can compare to me?
Al hassanatu aindi bi ashri amsali hawa azid wa wa saito aindi bi misli hawa aafu wa akfar
do you not see that I take one good deed one tiny good deed every single good deed that you do and I reward you ten times for it in fact even more but I count your single sin as a single sin and when you repent I even forgive that and reward you for your repentance then where are you going?
I personally feel that this Hadith really portrays the Rahmaniyah and the Rahimiyah of our Creator.
You know His love, His emotion is the kind of...
I mean there is...
You will not find anyone more humble than Allah.
And does He need to be humble?
I mean He is the Creator, right?
I mean look at this humility.
I mean this statement just...
you know...
You take one step, I will run towards you You walk away from me, I will chase you I mean that is...
that is...
you know, if He is this humble being a creator, then how are we so arrogant being creation?
And you know, His love is just not a word that could be measured in words and it can only be judged through His actions and all we see is His actions
so I hope that you know I'll end it here I hope that I was able to explain the difference between Ar-Rahman and Rahim and give everybody a really good understanding of what the word Rahma means and how perfect Ar-Rahman and Rahim come together to to capture that emotion
Wagharudawan Alhamdulillahi Rabbil Alameen Wassalatu Wassalam Ala Rasuli Sayyidam Mohammadin Fatim Alabeen Wassidul Musaleen Waalahi Wassi Alibnabi Talib Ashrafil Wassien Waalala Immatiman Zuriyatiman Tahirim Wassalim Al Fatih.